there is a new trend in parenting which
is they are teaching science and
rational thought instead of religion
crazy
alright Cara we're gonna start with you
on this one to me this seems like a very
evolved way of thinking and you're
you're giving sort of a decent honest
set of rules to go out into the world
with I think you're going to agree with
that is is this how you were brought up
because you are that's raised Mormon I
was raised Mormon and half my family
still mark functioning a highly
functioning Mormon I left the church at
14 yeah I know a fair amount of X
Mormons who who did something similar
also like I said half probably more than
half my family is still in the church I
have friends who were raised with no
religion in the household and that are
atheist now I have friends who were
raised with no religion that found
religion later I think that it's really
anybody's journey
what does frustrate me a little bit is
when people when I tell people that I
was raised Mormon they go that's why
you're an atheist and it's like no
that's not why I'm an atheist I mean I
think everybody's story contributes to
this really multifaceted kind of you
know woven picture of why they believe
what they believe or have lack of belief
I personally think that raising children
I don't like the headline to believe in
science like when people go oh you
believe in evolution yeah and that's
something I would have to at back when I
was teaching biology and teaching
psychology that's something I had to
fight against a lot that it's not a
belief structure it's it's a method but
um I personally think that not believing
in God is the default position children
are indoctrinated to have religious
ideas right if you didn't teach them
religion they wouldn't naturally be
religious they will eventually find
religion children nationally ask
questions they're naturally curious they
asked why they could fit why face why is
this why is the sky blue why is this
happening so then the adults around them
in the authorities or the people that
give them that information they're the
ones that choose to say the sky is blue
because of you know refractory this and
that or they get to stay because God
made it that way and simplify things for
not only transits
that's easier for real all right exactly
they don't know the real answer mom and
dad aren't necessarily educated and
don't know the answer or they are
educated and they're just busy so
they're just like because it is that way
and what scares me is that the headline
is that this is now a trend but science
is being chiming it's like religious and
you raise your child in a church you
should still be you know kind of
fostering scientific curiosity I mean I
went to church I grew up in basically
like it was Methodists and Presbyterians
and of bounced back back and forth so in
a Christian you know sunday-school
certainly learned all about you know
that form of in my school that I went to
we learned science and we learned math
and they did not tell us that it was
because ever because of God we learned
evolution and even in my church they
left it open to interpretation they were
like you know there's a bit of science
in this world a little bit of faith I
mean there's such a combination I feel
like that was so so much more
appropriate for a child than to tell a
child be less curious about facts right
so as two people that grew up with some
sort of religious background in a way
you have to kind of give it credit for
the two forming your thoughts now right
even if you would prefer that every
child be brought up with the church I am
Who I am because of all of my experience
everyone you know everyone is I can't
say that I would be better or worse if I
hadn't been raised Mormon I think I have
a perspective that a lot of people don't
have I'll tell you I probably enjoyed
the Book of Mormon the play at least
there's that no I mean yeah everybody is
who they are because of because of their
vast experiences but I personally if I
decided to have children would
definitely raise them to be curious
scientific thinkers and I would want
them to be able to explore all these
different aspects on their own I would
want them to be able to come to their
own conclusions based on available
evidence but not based on indoctrination
and I think that's the important
distinction that yeah and how would you
feel if you brought your child up in
this scientific learning I think space
but then they became religious
that's a part of the Rangers well people
kids are going to explore and she was
whatever they want I was very grateful
that my parents let me I went to Temple
I went to Mormon Church I went to
everything I've been to a mosque when I
was a child my parents let me go
wherever I went to Catholic school
classes with my friend out of curiosity
and my parents were cool with that and
my parents were kind of conservative and
not necessarily the Republican you
wouldn't necessarily consider them
progressive but in terms of that they
really allowed me to explore so I feel
like that allows a child to make
decisions so if my child came to me
because I fully plan on raising my child
in science and math were so behind as a
country by the way just to interject
that in a country that falls so far
behind in science and math for it to be
a problem or a new trend for us to be
teaching that's just that that's the
craziest part we want to be competitive
and we're going over those our jobs
people overseas and Obama you're putting
people in China and people are losing
their minds that when you call you know
a call center for tech help that you're
getting somebody in Indonesia or India
or something well then teach your kids
science in America and don't teach them
that God is one who's gonna fix your
iPhone the only reason I'm not getting
us worked up right now is because I
literally say this every day anybody who
actually like like follow some of the
work that I've done before I mean cuz
that's what I do I'm a science
communicator that's my background and
the whole thing is about like we need to
think more scientifically we need more
evidence-based thinking more critical
thinking and the beauty of this is that
all the religious nut jobs who don't
agree with you guys on this are gonna be
yelling at us in the comments correct
can't wait I gotta know they're doing it
for ya